dimanche 28 mars à 15 heures j'ai
escaladé la tour montparnasse
j'étais sur place déjà à midi le temps
que je me mette en place
psychologiquement du grimp et donc sa
durée 40 minutes
j'étais avec du str ap mes doigts avec
des chaussons d'escaladé et un sac
magnésie pour éponger la moiteur des
mains pondra grimpe n'y a pas la place
pour la peur l'objectif est d'après vous
osez la structure se sentir bien avec
c'est juste la grimpe les la
concentration c'est à dire que je suis
pas stressé c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
une anxiété qui est présente mais en
tout cas pas la peur la juste la
concentration est l'objectif
[Musique]
l'en-v 10h je suis préparée depuis 14
ans a fait 13 14 ans je fais des
escalades je suis préparé en grimpant
voit depuis toujours c'est que je fais
des escalades depuis très longtemps je
connais mon corps je sais que j'aime ça
je sais que jamais ce cas là je sais
quelles sont mes compétences j'ai
toujours aimé grimpé quand j'étais petit
je grimpais sur les rochers de
fontainebleau les tout petits cailloux
depuis toujours en fait depuis je sais
marcher
j'essaye de grimper 13 ans après rien
n'a changé je veux toujours grimper sans
corde les façades urbaine
je me prépare de manière générale pour
des ascensions comme ça comme celle là
grâce à notre monde escalade et pour
cette ascension en particulier quatre
cinq mois que je me préparais notamment
grimpant sur la structure qu'il ya dans
mon garage ou alors en grimpant
directement au pied des tours et
escaladé la tour lgi la tour ariane à la
défense j'ai escaladé d'autres tours
aussi moins haute mais assez durs dans
paris moi je pense que c'est un sport
comme les autres en ce que donne tout le
monde en est capable en fait avec de
l'entraînement c'est pas quelque chose 6
hors du commun sports extrêmes comme un
autre je pense
[Musique]
en termes d'inspiration alain robert
forcément être une source d'inspiration
énorme depuis tout petit c'est un
grimpeur hors norme ce soit d'ailleurs
en grimpe urbaine ou en grimpant voies
naturelles
je suis un que j'ai regardé introduction
de mission impossible 2 quand tom cruise
escalade une falaise à manu sens sans
aucune protection là j'ai dit à mon père
tout de suite ça que je veux faire je
veux pas dire quel sera mon prochain
tour exactement en fait de tout mais là
je ne le sais pas donc je ne connais pas
les conséquences judiciaires de l'
escalade de la tour montparnasse
en revanche je pense que j'irais bien
faire un tour à barcelone dans les mois
à venir